Pessoal, notícia ruim. Você sabia que
pode estar tomando veneno no seu café da
manhã? Pois é. A Anvis acabou de proibir
três marcas de café que estavam
vendendo, sabe o quê? Toxina de fungo.
Veja bem, as marcas Melissa, Pingo Preto
e Oficial foram pegas vendendo o café
adulterado com ocratoxina.
que essa substância, meu amigo, é
produzida por fungos e vai direto pro
seu rim, danifica o seu rim, é
nefrotóxica, destrói as células renais e
pior, pode até causar tumores a longo
prazo. Sabe o que mais me revolta? Eles
colocavam café torrado e moído no
rótulo, mas na verdade tinha grão cru,
resíduos e até matéria estranha. É café
fake mesmo. A toxina aparece quando o
café é mal armazenado, com umidade e
calor. Então fica a dica, confere aí sua
marca de café e se for uma dessas, joga
fora agora. Ah.